Parks and Rec you guys wrapped it up it
must been very tough saying goodbye to
the cast yeah I mean I feel like it's
been said to death at this point but we
were all really close and you know
everyone got each other gifts and stuff
and um you know Aubrey Plaza's and I are
very close we've known each other before
the show and became really good friends
on the show and she gave me this very
nice gift and I wanted to tell you guys
about this gift so she gave me this gift
this is really her this is a real thing
she gave me she wrote me this nice note
and it said these no words could
describe how much I care about you but a
pack of My Blood and a shard of my hair
I give you a spell for when we're apart
put me somewhere safe and always keep me
in your heart love Aubrey and she gave
me this and I was like oh my god yeah
that's pretty awkward
Aubrey gave you this is her blood and
her hair her blood in her hair I was
like this is the greatest sweetest gift
like I was like this is so this is so
like beautiful and it's like such an
Aubree gift and I loved it right yeah so
cut to this weekend I saw her and and
and we were hanging out and somehow this
gift came up and my girlfriend was just
like well ah brie like that's not really
your blood right and she's like no I
know it's like what
that's not your blood anything I don't
know it's like a jelly or something
I was like what's the hare she's like
that's not my hair I was like so what
what is this thing you just gave me
trash like that yeah a bottle you've
been carrying that around I've been
keeping it in my heart cone nothing
you